[Music]
gigi hadid and Zayn Malik cuddle up for
vote the 22 year old model and her
singer beau look totally in love posing
for the August issue of the fashion mag
check out this adorable photo of them
snuggling in coordinated track suits
together gigi insane admit they love
shopping in each other's closets Gigi
explaining quote it's not about gender
it's about like shaped and what feels
good on you that day but fashion isn't
their only passion the blonde beauty
gushed about her man's body art during
the round of 73 questions which was aims
tattoos are your favorite I feel like I
have a new kind of infatuation with a
different one every week I really like
the details as for the most romantic
things ain't ever done a couple years
ago on Valentine's Day we went on a boat
trip it was really nice
last November Gigi revealed what she
loves most about her leading man to ET
she's obviously so gorgeous but really
the way that we could have conversations
and kind of just were really interested
in the same things and it was really
easy
[Music]
you